Eric is on the line in Los Angeles hi
Eric welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
to you how can I help
well so I did my yearly budget for 2018
and I did my net worth and I got to get
after it you know life or death ghazal
intensity I'm looking at probably
working seven days a week with Saturday
night and Sunday night off but my wife
she's really not on board with it and so
my question is I mean is there a point
where you just forge ahead and drag your
spouse behind you or I mean how does
that work okay so what is the goal
you're trying to accomplish with all
this work well I mean number one I got
to make ends meet but number two you
know did the net worth and I'm negative
192,000 yeah but I mean you have a lot
of death yeah okay personal debt other
than your home I don't own my home it's
all personal debt it's a little bit
everything it's it's student loans it's
taxes it's medical bills it's and that
total yeah it's everything you say not
to do that total is 192,000 yeah
how much of that student loan debt
probably about thirty of it okay and
what's the rest of it about seventy
thousand of it is actually tax debt ooh
so you end up $70,000 in taxes well
because I have a I have a child support
that I have to pay and it's it's quite
high and just cost of living here in
California no honey he's called
supportive child support does not cause
you to be seventy thousand dollars
behind with the IRS how'd you end up now
the IRS yeah if I but if just budgeting
month-to-month if I pay child support
and pay insurance and try to keep a roof
over my head and
pay taxes it couldn't do it so I'm
paying the very minimal so you're
selling taxes so yourself employees say
again you're self-employed no no I work
I work for a company yeah but how did
you not pay your taxes you've you you're
under withholding that's much
yeah I'm claiming like married and nine
okay so what is your household income
eighty seven thousand okay well that's
not working do you got to get the I
knows right because the IRS is gonna
kill you
their penalties and their interest is
the height is higher than any other
thing you can do so 70 of the 192 is
back taxes and then and student loans is
30 so that's a hundred of the 990 what's
the other big pieces we owe probably
about fifty on two cars okay and the
most expensive I'm sorry which car is
the most expensive probably we picked up
a car from Carmack's
it was kind of an emergency situation
and so we had to pick up an extra car
last year and that's what do you know
right I think the ten day pay off on it
is is like eighteen thousand or so then
the other one has to be more expensive
if you go fifty own cars 32 on the other
car I'm sorry you owe 32 on your other
car yeah about okay you got cars you
can't afford your car yeah and I'm I'm
paying $1,000 a month just in vehicle
you're not denying gas or insurance or
anything yeah you're dying here you
gonna sell this man these cars got to go
both of them and you got to get a couple
of beaters while you work your way out
of the rest of this mess and so I think
what you need to do is is not announced
to your wife that you're gonna work all
the time I think you need to sit down
with her and say hey let's look at this
together and you start unpacking these
numbers
and showing her you know we make 87 and
we have this much in debt here and this
much and we have this card debt we have
this and this and this and when you lay
all that out in front of her if she is a
grown-up she's gonna freak and say yes
you have to work all the time and yes we
have to start selling some stuff and yes
but if she's a child if she's just a
little girl a princess then she's gonna
go well you just did whatever you need
to be there you know and she's gonna
just you know be a but in which case you
need marriage counseling but I think she
doesn't have the information I don't
think she's a child I think you just
announced to her like you did these
stupid but car purchases and not holding
enough out on your taxes what you were
gonna go do instead of sitting down and
showing her where you all were and why
you need to work like a maniac I agree
you need to work like a maniac
because you got a real mess you got to
sell some cars
you got to get on a really tight budget
and this family's gonna have to change a
lot of stuff Eric you are about to hit
the wall man you're not far from it at
all
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy the
book the Total Money Makeover to try to
help you - this is the Dave Ramsey show